Speaker 1: An NRA convention attendee
was brutally fact checked on video,
completely disproven in real time, and still
says, Well, I still believe the same thing.
This is an incredible, epistemological,
instructive event. This is from our friends
over at The Good Liars who are doing such
good work. The Good Liars are Dorham Stiffler
and Jason Selvin. This is a great example about
how confronting people with facts is a useless in
the face of their worldview and their preexisting
notions. If the facts support their conclusion,
they'll use the facts. If the
facts contradict their conclusion,
they'll ignore the facts or say the facts don't
matter or that it's fake news or whatever.
Check this out. This is just unbelievable.
Speaker 3: Our people and more crime is committed
and more people are killed with hammers every year
than guns. Look at the facts. I will look that up.
I don't think that's true. Actually, it's true in
the United States, though, sir. That is true. Look
it up. It's on. You can Google it. It's true. It's
actually true. So the number of murder victims
and the weapons used. Okay. Number one, handguns,
8029. Number two, firearms type, not stated.
4863. Number three, knives or cutting instruments,
personal weapons, fists, feet, then rifles
at 455, then blunt objects, clubs, hammers,
393. The 300, the hammers. That stat is just
wrong. Back to your question. Second Amendment
is still my right and it's still important to me.
Speaker 1: Notice how confident this guy is
in something that is not only obviously wrong
but verifiably wrong and verified to his
face and notice how quickly he abandons it
as instructive and informative to his opinion.
Going in part of his support for firearms
was. Hammers are much more deadly. He's then
shown. Hammers are not much more deadly.
The fact is completely debunked, but now his
opinion is no longer based on that. Now it's just
it's in the Second Amendment and that's it.
So the format of this, if we wanted to kind of
boil this down to a kind of fundamental logic,
the format is here's something I made up
that supports my conclusion. Well, but that thing
isn't true. You just invented that and it's wrong.
And then yes, but it actually doesn't matter. And
I still believe the same thing because it didn't
really make a difference to my opinion. Oh, okay.
By the way, think about hammers for a second.
Okay. Imagine that we took away all the hammers.
All right. Wouldn't deaths deaths from hammers go
down? They almost certainly would. But people
might replace the hammer with something else,
like a gun. Well, if those looking to kill
people with hammers instead get a gun,
they'll probably be able to kill more
people. Do any of us disagree with that? No.
The gun is much more deadly than the hammer. Well,
then why isn't the opposite true? Right. If we
take away the guns, wouldn't deaths from guns go
down? And they would say, Yeah, but they might get
something else like a hammer? Well, you're going
to kill way fewer people with a hammer than with
a gun. It's sort of like the logic is accepted
by almost everyone. When you go hammer to gun,
if you hand someone a hammer versus a gun, who
are they most likely to be? How many people are
they most likely to be able to kill people? Except
it going one direction? But when you say, well, if
everybody was if the mass shooters all had swords,
wouldn't they kill fewer people now? They'd still
figure out a way to kill just as many people
because the guns aren't really a factor. What
that doesn't make any sense makes no sense at all.
So an incredibly instructive moment. And remember,
the facts only matter if they are convenient.
And if they aren't convenient, they no longer
matter. We'll have this clip on our Instagram
page, which you can find at David Pakman show.